take a look at this story from
timcast.com
biden breaks his 118 day streak of no
interviews with appearance on jimmy
kimmel live jokes about sending
republicans to jail
same thing wow it's all projection yep
but we're at this point now where joe
biden goes on this primetime show i
think they only get like a million to
two million viewers anyway so it's not
like it and they're mostly old people so
you're competitive
i mean i think we get more in the key
demo than they do
but he goes on the show and it's funny
to him to say you gotta you gotta send
the republicans to jail but everyone
laughs and they cheer for it
we're we're beyond the point where
there's negotiation
right now i'm looking at some of these
other prominent leftists on youtube and
they're all like january 6th hearing
blah
and they don't know or care about what
really happened no i'll give you a good
example because i love bringing it up
when i said on this show
when it comes to trespassing charges a
person has to have been warned for it to
be criminal right the people on january
6 who were led in the building by police
could not have known because it's a
public building and the cops opened the
door and let them in
now the rioters the people who fought
with cops on the other side of the
building yeah right they're gonna get
arrested they're gonna be charged they
were fighting it was violent
but they're we're gonna see a lot of
people who fight it and they're gonna
say i wasn't trespassing the door was
open we've already seen it happen the
young turks run a story saying i'm an
idiot i'm making it up
they they they conflate
what really happened that day between
the different sides of the building with
all just rioting
and it turns out i was right the whole
time but those are the kind of people
who are going to watch jimmy kimmel and
are going to cheer for this and there's
no negotiating with them because i can
say to them they can watch my video
where i say specifically the rioters
should be charged and the people on the
other side of the building who are
lended by cops you can't charge or it's
going to be difficult and they should be
able to see like they should be able to
respond very simply with like okay those
are fact statements instead they just
say we don't care we want to go to war
with you we want to hate you so i don't
see how there's reconciliation i don't
see how there's there's a resolution if
we can it's like
it's almost like looking into a a portal
into a parallel universe watching this
interview with joe biden and jimmy
kimmel jimmy kimmel's like the
republicans don't play by the rules you
know how do you how he's like well if if
we play like them then then we're gonna
we're gonna our democracy's in jeopardy
and i'm like what are the republicans
doing right literally what have they
done
have they passed bills no they're in the
minority so what are they doing that is
breaking the rules they're not doing
anything
but joe biden go on tv and they all
believe it
yeah i think watching that it's like you
know scott adams talks about one screen
two movies playing the same time we're
all saying something different right
i think if you know the truth you're not
on the left if you believe the lies
you're on the left that's what happens
well you so you mentioned trump saying
that hillary would be in jail and
compared the two part of what's
different about this is biden is
referring much more vaguely to
republicans and certainly he's referring
to republican political leaders i think
we can infer that but donald trump was
talking about a specific
political leader who is viewed by the
vast majority of the public as being
corrupted friends commitment but who who
committed who committed a specific crime
and it completed a specific
exactly
exactly
yeah i mean because look i was in the
military and and having the clearance
that i had if you just left a document
or a folder on the table that said top
secret if you leave that in there empty
and you leave the room you can be
charged oh for sure it's an empty it's
an empty folder oh but it was just yoga
emails right that's what you said look
we all smash our phone with a hammer
every now and again that's true yeah
well you know when when when uh you know
you work for the government you're
supposed to take a hammer to your your
phone so that
it's the craziest thing they did but
they did it right and i heard people say
well maybe she didn't take because
there's courses that you have to take
when you're stuff right so they're like
well maybe she didn't take the course
and likely she didn't but it doesn't
mean that you're not culpable for
violating law yeah well you have a
clearance it's not an excuse right
she should be according to the law
disqualified from holding office for
destroying public record yep
now
that's never going to happen i mean
she's disqualified because people aren't
going to vote for her
see that's the funny thing though right
voting works and a lot of people just
want to say it doesn't work but i'm like
donald trump is kind of proof that if
people look nobody wanted to vote for
hillary clinton
slightly more wanted donald trump
donald trump wins the vast majority of
people even 18 months before they voted
for donald trump if you'd have told them
you're going to vote for donald trump
for president they would have left it
yeah
that's the reality a lot of prominent
never trumpers are now on the trump
train right there you know we've had
people on the show where in 2015 16 they
were like trump's awful we can't allow
him and then they're like well you know
he wasn't that bad after all they ended
up voting for him
i think there's a lot wrong with donald
trump but i certainly think he did he
did a pretty good job in a lot of areas
and it's remarkable how he went from
2019 no pandemic best numbers of our
lives best economy then a pandemic
happens and everyone's like it's trump's
fault when it's like it was the
governor's even right now i have no
problem saying a lot of the issues we're
facing are remnants of what the
governors did and it's not just
democrats the democrats are the ones who
held on forever and the republicans
backed away from it but i don't blame
biden for the fact we had a pandemic i
blame him for specific policies and he's
enacted since he became president right
you have people all the time especially
campaigning they want to know where
you're standing on trump and the single
question that you respond to people with
and this is the god's honest truth is
listen the reality is for the most
americans what we really care about is
how much money we're paying at the pump
and how much we're paying for food
that's what we care about and so i tell
people are you better today
under this administration or two years
ago
for me it's very clear that my family my
business we were much better two years
ago than everybody was whether they want
to admit it or not where do you stand on
trump that's that is the stance i mean i
voted for the man twice i'll be happy
vote for him again are you kidding me i
would vote for just about anybody
compared to this [ __ ] that's in office
right now are you kidding me i vote for
you for president i've only known you
for two days
no i mean let's be real luke would be a
substantially better president than joe
biden and it's not because luke is a
good good at policy it's because joe
biden is a decrepit old senile man
senile old man that's not a compliment
you're not helping me out here yeah it's
like on a scale of like one to ten where
one is just the absolute worst and
you're just like something's wrong with
you and ten is you're the best leader
ever luke's a four and biden's a one wow
okay so it makes real
that makes that makes luke it's four
times better than biden and to be
fair first act as president of the
united states to be abolished the u.s
government of the united states and make
everything states rights yeah well you
just went from the affordable care act
for themselves abolish all the
government agencies the atf immediately
irs federal reserve all goes up going
back on the gold standard uh three
things that are illegal
that's kind of weird but i can't i was
born and said illegal
i was born in poland i came to be a
president oh man oh thank you but thank
you thank you about me
if arnold didn't fix that yet you're not
going to you don't do that oh haven't we
only had like one irish catholic
president uh yeah yes i believe kennedy
uh okay so that didn't work out well
yeah exactly it worked out well for him
yeah yeah
he tried to move against the big banks
and uh you know yeah and the cia too
yeah i've heard this i've heard you
could put a pumpkin in the white house
and the country would run better we did
yeah it was very gorgeous
the reality is the policies under trump
made us stronger and a stronger america
makes a safer world we've seen that i
mean for crying out loud the man had
peace deals in the middle east i'm 41
years old we heard our whole life it's
never gonna happen there's never gonna
be peace in the middle east and he
started making peace deals i mean how
did how i don't understand they panicked
when that happened yeah they should have
they didn't like it no yeah the
establishment was like but but we need
to blow up kids in the middle east what
are we gonna do we can have these these
peace agreements
oh they're they're so mad they're so
livid trump was getting our troops out
of syria he's got a timeline for for
getting out of afghanistan he was
constantly complaining about how he got
troops everywhere he's like why do we
have troops in in germany this makes no
sense and i'm just like this guy knows
what's up well you know he he did move
him around he did bomb certain areas as
well but he did move troops out of
somalia me bomb terrorism uh generals of
terrorist organizations well you know it
depends it's it's the babel
there's some questions to to ask
specifically when it comes to american
foreign policy and the unaccountable
drone strikes but he did take troops out
of somalia and stopped operations there
biden just a couple weeks ago introduced
more troops into somalia and just two
days ago started launching airstrikes
inside of that region
um just two days ago so look the reality
is anybody who advocates for war as
somebody who's been to it twice has
either never been to war or is profiting
from it that's my stance on it yeah i
believe that the vast majority of
americans do not want their sons and
daughters to go to wars and foreign
soils spill american blood on foreign
soils that has nothing to do with
american interests that's i'm telling
you right now that's where the vast
majority of americans and what happened
to what happened that was a left
position that was like the left was all
about this right and i remember the
2000s when it was just all protests
obama's like i'm gonna get our troops up
and then he put our troops in uh let's
get him let's bring him back home bring
back our boys and then look where we are
well it's funny
he
obama said that he was gonna withdraw
the troops draw down our forces the
first thing he does when he get when he
gets in he says it's bombing families
immediately now
family which uh the biden administration
targeted those children and then trump
targeted as soon as he got into office
as well so as soon as trump got in
office there was a commando raid in
yemen where
now here's here's the challenge
barack obama ordered a drone strike
which did result in the killing of a 16
year old american citizen in yemen why
the u.s bombed a civilian restaurant in
yemen we have no real explanation they
said oh we're trying to get a terror
leader and they end up blowing up some
kid an american citizen
now a lot of people point this out and i
think it's fair to donald trump one of
the first things he does when he gets uh
inaugurated when he becomes president is
order a commando raid which resulted in
the death of a seven-year-old girl
abdulrahman al-laki's little sister
however
the the death of
abdulrahman abu alaki the 16 year old is
well known and documented and admitted
the death of the little girl is claimed
by the family so there is a different
difference there
i still think we shouldn't be trump
should not have been ordering commando
raids in yemen or helping saudi arabia
in this manner but there's a slight
difference in the con confirmation of
these stories
yeah lots of things especially when it
comes to geoplastic geopolitics that
become a lot more complicated a lot uh
deeper down the rabbit hole than we
could even understand on them especially
when we hear about the public stories
and what really happened there's usually
a big discrepancy between between both
of those oh absolutely i mean it quite
honestly
we were talking about earlier we really
don't even know what to believe anymore
there's so much there's so much
propaganda and this is from i mean not
just our government from everywhere
there's so much propaganda now that
nobody knows what to believe anymore
that's a huge problem if the american
people don't know who to trust for
information
it's almost like that's on purpose it's
a demoralization you're a besman but i
mean especially about foreign policy
right it's really difficult to get
information about that and report
accurately and so much of we the
information we get turns out to be
untrue you mentioned that uh you're a
veteran it's also interesting because i
found that that was not as important an
issue to me until i started becoming
friends with people who had fought in
some of these wars and they ended up red
pilling me on american foreign policy
there's this idea that veterans are
pro-war in some way i have found that
absolutely hasn't been the case and if
i'm not mistaken was was ron paul not
the most donated to candidate by us
service members yeah absolutely yeah so
the people who actually see this stuff
almost always end up opposing and his
policy was non-interventionalism
troops back into the united states
priority issues here inside of the
united states rather than of course
being the policemen of the world which
which i think there's some important
context to especially with the way that
plan has played out in places like
afghanistan that was an absolute mess
and a huge investment of wasted money
that made the situation that much worse
on the ground and i i just want to say
this i'm glad you mentioned that just in
case this didn't hit home for any of the
audience members who aren't entirely
familiar with ron paul and maybe just
sort of vaguely know him as libertarian
probably the most anti-war presidential
candidate this country has
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you